this was the moment when american
history was made on this vote the a's
are 53
the nays are 47
and this nomination is confirmed
when the nation's first black female
vice president announced the
confirmation of the first black woman to
the u.s supreme court
never never has a black woman held the
title of justice
katanji brown jackson will be the first
and i believe the first of more to come
kitanji brown jackson's confirmation
passed by the narrow margin of 53 to 47
with three republicans joining all 50
democrats in voting yes she's within the
mainstream she's also highly qualified
intelligent capable person and i
wish you the very best
the remaining senate republicans voted
no some voicing concern over jackson's
work representing guantanamo bay
detainees when she served as a federal
public defender others accused her of
being a tool for the political left i
believe she will prove to be
the furthest left
of any justice to have ever served on
the supreme court members of this
committee jackson defended against that
assertion during her confirmation
hearing i interpret and apply the law to
the facts of the case before me
without fear or favor consistent with my
judicial oath jackson has nearly a
decade of experience on the federal
bench she's the daughter of public
school teachers and also served on the
federal sentencing commission she joined
president joe biden to watch the
confirmation vote from the white house
jackson will replace the moderate
liberal justice stephen breyer when he
retires in july leaving the supreme
court's conservative super majority
unchanged it's very unlikely that
justice jackson will be able to convince
a conservative justice to cross party
lines and vote with the liberal justices
on the controversial issues
but jackson's confirmation is a symbolic
win for democrats and the biden
administration at age 51 she will likely
have decades to sit on the u.s supreme
court and her supporters say just as
importantly she will serve as a
trailblazing role model and inspiration
for generations to come
heidi joe castro al jazeera washington